for you uh going on tour has got to be
like uh you
know I always hear that there's like ups
and downs of tour like M are you guys
doing the bus thing yeah I so tell me if
this is true or not but I've heard that
you're not supposed to [__] on the bus
is this true yes oh my gosh and somebody
[__] on the bus last year it was
crazy I was like what the [__] and we
all knew who it was but yeah it was him
no I ain't going to put him out like
that I ain't going to put him out like
that but you know who you is yeah like I
always hear like there's like one rule
do not [__] on the bus and the crazy
thing is the driver told us don't [__]
on the bus and somebody just had to be
that person but so that's one thing
that's one I hear that like socks and
draws are very important on tour like
you can never have more like at least I
heard you got to have like extra like
brand new socks and draws like T because
doing laundry is a pain in the ass oh
yeah I do that anyway though t or not
like just in life yeah I just be like
you don't you don't wash like you just
throw away and re and Reby honestly I'll
be buying too much [__] I ain't going to
lie like I'll be in the store that's why
I really don't like going to the store
cuz I'll just see some [__] and be like
oh I want this I want this like and I
don't even be needing it do you get rid
of like like do you give your stuff away
yeah like recently this year was the
first time I did that in like years I
got all my [__] out of Atlanta cuz I had
a place there and like I just gave it to
my mom and told her to like give it away
he mom give this it was like a bunch of
shoes like big ass boxes of shoes and
clothes and you know what else was in
the Box what your Pomeranian that you
your mom yeah you're like here give all
this [__] away here's the dog no but I
love Sosa though she just she's very
hyper like I thought she was going to
grow out of that but like she' be
shaking like jumping going crazy I'm
glad she still remembers me though
because I'd be thinking like damn I
wonder if she gonna remember me like
like you pulled up recently and she got
excited yeah that's tight yeah she
didn't forget I always wonder like cuz
you know there's rappers who will like
get rid of Air Force Ones after one wear
oh yeah and I'll be
like one wear is crazy maybe two where
did the shoes
go like I don't know they need to have a
whole facility for that [__] yeah like
Benny The Butcher wore a pair of shoes
on stage and he was just going to leave
them in the in the green room and I was
like I know a lot of people who do that
I ain't going to lie hey I picked them
up I looked at the size he my son will
fit these took them [__] home I said
here's here's some Benny The Butcher Air
Force Ones for you kid right brand new
one
wear that's funny that's 90 bucks oh no
they're like a buck 10 now for pair they
used to be 90 Jesus inflation is crazy
has inflation affected you at all um I
mean I'm still blessed I can't say like
it's affected me but I've definitely
noticed the changes for sure like even
in stores like [__] that was like a
certain price yeah like back when I was
like like even five years ago even like
two years ago two years ago this shit's
great like gas I mean you drive around
La you see the gas prices are ridiculous
I stay at the gas station but like
that's not a good place to stay at it's
really not the way she said that she's
like y I stay at the gas station I'm out
here looking for Florida man you know
what I'm saying no my car drinks a yes
oh you have a G wagon mhm are you based
out here or Cali or tell nobody I live
well listen if you anybody who has to be
in California anymore than they need to
be the gas here is $7 a gallon it's
[__] terrible that's crazy it is
horrible shout out to the G wagons yeah
you know what's great about a G wagon is
when you bought the G wagon did you ride
it off what you mean it's over 6,000 lb
so if you have a LLC or you have like a
S Corporation you could write off that
entirely I did okay she did it I did tax
volume one with flow Millie right now
yeah N G wagons eat a lot of gas shout
out to the G-Wagon yeah so I'll be
trying not to like but you right though
that's not a safe place to be like you
shouldn't stay at the gas station you I
would send some if I'm you I got the
gasg I be like hey I need yall to go
fill my [__] up real quick yeah I don't
trust nobody in my [__] that's another
thing I'm very like if you [__] up my
[__] like I'm going be mad yeah I feel
you I I'd rather [__] it up myself was a
G wagon like coming up like one of your
dream cars honestly no it was like
really like McLaren's Corvettes and all
that McLaren yeah you got some you know
do you know uh you know white clef right
oh yeah he was the first rapper with
McLaren when I was a kid he was in that
uh magazine uh it was like King Magazine
but they did a car version of it yeah
but anyway it was like a 1.5 million
dollar car he had I never even heard of
McLaren before White had one yeah them
them shit's as hard as [__] like I ain't
going to lie it's an impractical car
though what that mean it's just like
what are you supposed to do with it like
no one can come with you one person can
come that's why okay I ain't going to
lie cuz that's the one thing I don't
like about sports cars it's like two
doors like if you go get groceries like
I can't really get groceries in this car
I can buy like a little something you
know what I'm saying like yeah but you
can't really enjoy [__] but and it sit
so low like and like yeah if you park it
you might hit the [__] little little
divider thing in the parking yeah it's
too it's too many cons I ain't going to
lie I feel like once you have a big
truck like yours M it's like yo I could
run over [__] I could pull up as far as
I want in a parking spot not worry about
scraping my [__] facts but the only
thing I have to worry about now is
like parking garages my car too high
yeah that and not seeing people bro cuz
I I ain't going to tell y'all no don't
tell us that you hit somebody no I ain't
hit she's like I didn't see somebody and
I mean [__] all right
no I ain't hit nobody I a hit nobody but
ID be like damn like I didn't even see
that but